こんにちは！
YouTuber捕獲委員会 委員長
はじめしゃちょーです
よろしくお願いします
皆さん
YouTuber 捕まえたこと ありますでしょうか
まあ 今 世の中には いろんなYouTuberが
たくさん いるんですけども
どのYouTuberにも、特徴があるので
その特徴さえ つかめば、どんなYouTuberでも
あなたの家で捕まえることができるかも！しれません
で 僕1回
捕まえたことがあるYouTuberがいましてー
HIKAKINさん。捕まえたことがあります
ヒカキンさんはサングラスが大好きなのでー
サングラスを こう 並べておくと
大好きなサングラスに こう 吸い寄せられて、
ヒカキンさんが来る という。
見事 大成功して
ヒカキンさんを捕まえ…たことがあるんですけどもー
今回 捕まえようと思うYouTuberは、この方！
SEIKINさんです！！
[拍手]
で セイキンさん なんですけどもー
いろいろ調査をした結果
あのYouTuberの特徴としましては
チョコエッグが。
大好きだ ということが、わかっております
なので 今回 こちらに大量のチョコエッグを
準備させていただいたんですけども
セイキンさん チョコエッグ大好きすぎて 一時期 すごいチョコエッグの動画を出してたんですけどもー
最近 出してないんですよね
7ヶ月前にですね、
チョコエッグを120個 開封してるんスよ
凄くないですか？
普通の人間は チョコエッグ 120個も買えませんからね
そこがセイキンさんのポイントなんですよ
私は見抜いてしまいました
そこがセイキンさんの
あのYouTuberは チョコエッグが大好きすぎて
チョコエッグに目がない
そして ここ 7 ヶ月
チョコエッグの動画を出していないということは
セイキンさんの心の中に 秘めたる
チョコ エッグに対する チョコエッグ欲が爆発寸前で
もう あの人 今 チョコエッグを見ると、
いてもたっても いられないぐらい 興奮してしまう
そんな極限の状態なんですよ 今 セイキンさんは。
そんな中ですよ！
もし
多分 セイキンさんは チョコエッグが好きなんでー
来ます！
もう 静岡に来て この、こうやって 吸い寄せられて
チョコエッグのあとを伝って
捕獲ポイントまで 誘導できると思うので
今日の動画は 大量のチョコエッグを使って
セイキンさんを 捕獲してみようと思います
では チョコエッグ
設置開始ィ！！！
はいっ というわけで さっそく、
仕掛けていこうと思います
よーし…仕掛けてくぞぉ
最終的に、この本 見てる…うちに
捕まえようかなって感じです
よし
♪～
よーし…できました
ご覧ください
ここで まず 玄関まで行ってー
開けると 中に また あるので
これを こうやって 行って
で、曲がらせます
曲がって ここ ぐああっと 行って
で 階段になってるんで
このまま階段を登っていただきますと。
そして 階段の先に
ずーっと奥まで行くと、
なんと 3つも最後 置いてあるんです！
セイキンさんは、もう
1個のチョコエッグだと満足しないので
最後に 3つあることによって 大興奮を起こします
ここを 捕まえるポイントとします
そもそも セイキンさんが来るかどうかも
ちょっと 怪しいんですけどもー
僕の理論から言うと これでセイキンさんは
捕獲することができると 思います
では、来るのを、根気強く、待ちましょう。
[ｷｲｯ](ドア開ける音)
[ｷｨ ｶｼｬﾝ](ドア閉める音)
なんだこれ？(嬉しげ)
ｗｗｗｗｗ
よいしょっ
持ちきれないなぁ これ　…
ｗｗｗｗｗ
あそこ◎△＄♪×￥
ちょっ…
◎△＄♪×￥●
ふぅ〜(息を吐く)
[ｶﾞﾀﾝ]
[ﾋﾟｰﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ]
[ｶﾞﾁｬｯ]
お邪魔しま〜す(小声)
なんだこれ？？
え
あ〜こうなってんだ！
へぇ〜〜〜〜 ていうか
あー 向こう、向こうに 行けってこと？ これ
え…？
こっちだよね
ｗｗｗｗｗ
こっち ほぇ〜 こうなってんだ…
あー あー あー(納得)
オッケー
ああ〜 これだ！
動画で見たわ、これ
ていうか、ｗｗｗｗｗ
誰もいないんだけど ちょっと
いいんだろうか 勝手に入って
そして？
ｗｗｗｗｗ ちょっと…
はじめ）やあああああああっはっはっは！！！！ｗｗｗ
セイキン）ああああああっはっはっは！！！！ｗｗｗ
[通常ED]
はじめ）はっはっはっはｗｗｗ
セイキン）はっはっはっはｗｗｗ
はじめ）捕まえたぞぉーー！！！！
セイキン）なんだこりゃあ！！ｗ
セイキン）なんだ これｗｗ
セイキン）ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）チョコエッグを仕掛けまくったら、
セイキンさんが捕まえれるかどうかでした！
はじめ）無事 引っかかってくれましたねぇｗ
セイキン）や、てかさぁ いっぱいあるから 全部 持っ てきたほうがいいのかなぁって 思ったんだけどｗ
はじめ）ｗｗｗそうですかｗｗｗ
セイキン）持ちきれないだろうと思って 途中からｗｗ
はじめ）◎△＄♪×￥●＆％＃
セイキン）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）やー よかった 捕まえれて！
セイキン）なんじゃこりゃあ！ｗｗ
はじめ）というわけで みんなも、ぜひ、
セイキンさんを、捕まえてみようねぇっ☆
セイキン）捕まえよぉ〜〜〜！！